congratulations on getting through all
the lessons along the way I hope you've
thought about what it would take to
build your own mobile web app and maybe
you had some good ideas for a really big
project something that you think would
be successful or fun to build or a
project to scratch your own edge now if
you've enrolled in the full course
experience then you have access to
project evaluations and code review by
our Udacity coaches they want to help
you build a great mobile web app now in
the instructor comments below this video
you'll see a link to the rubric that
they'll be using to evaluate your
project you should take a look at it so
you know what they'll be looking for
you'll also find a link to an example
app we provided this in case you're not
sure what app you want to build if so
then just try building your own version
of that example app if you're still
unclear then talk to your coach they're
here to help you succeed in this course
and in your career